sur le vieux port de marseille personne
n'a oublié les retours triomphaux de la
calypso le navire mythique du commandant
cousteau
partir sur les traces de l'homme au
bonnet rouge est en soi une invitation à
prendre la mer
[Musique]
cette planète bleue n'at-il pas été le
premier en révéler au monde le spectacle
sublime mais aussi la profondeur d'âme
une catin sim qui a commencé ici au bord
de la méditerranée
l'eau de la méditerranée plein de cette
chaleur de ses caresses sensuelle qui
font naître le désir et apaise les
blessures
cousteau qu'un accident de voiture à
priver de son rêve de devenir aviateur
et à bien soigner les siennes
je me perds dans l'eau transparente
comme on se dilue dans un rêve
écrivait-il
la transparence l'héritage de l'immortel
au bonnet rouge et il a l'image de son
épée d'académicien en cristal de roche
comme l'effet lancelot ne me battre avec
toi quel bord armes symbolique des
poètes qui seuls peuvent changer le
monde
il aurait fallu que notre coupole au
lieu de vous recevoir à l'air libre
comme s'est platement l'habitude fut
remplie d'eau de mer jusqu'au bout'' et
vous seriez apparue dans une gerbe de
bulles cristalline suivi des caméras qui
vous perdent rarement de vue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bientôt j'obéirai à l'appel d'une
migration et tous ans alerté je
rejoindrai les miens en me rendant à
saint-andré de cubzac
je repense à ce poème écrit peu de temps
avant sa mort par le commandant cousteau
la ville natale du pacha de la calypso
est aussi son ultime escale
pourquoi après lui avoir dédié son
existence l'ancien officier de marine
n'at-il pas choisi la mer pour sépulture
mais ce caveau familial en vieilles
pierres des coteaux
pensez vraiment que la trace du corps
humain avec la famille c'était quelque
chose de très rassurant et profondément
comment dire je les dires sentimentale
il a été aux gens enfin dans toute sa
vie il a été aux autres et puis un jour
eh ben ils avaient envie de rentrer dans
la maison et la maison c'est là où il
était né la terre de son enfance sa
famille les gens qu'ils avaient aimé et
je ne crois qu'il ya un certain une
certaine idée de bien-être
à travers ça la disparition de captain
planet n'a pas seulement ému ses anciens
équipiers mais le monde entier de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
cousteau était disait ton plus populaire
que le général de gaulle du fin fond de
l'amérique latine
le maire de caldera un jour apportées à
saint-andré un superbe dauphin sculpté
en acajou l'animal et son bonnet rouge
se dresse aujourd'hui vers le chili vers
la tombe du commandant
on a toujours des visiteurs qui viennent
deux derniers de nouvelle zélande ont
fait un détour ici exprès pour rendre
hommage au commandant
saint-émilion pomerol sur ces coteaux la
ville prospère éternelle et fier je
n'aurais pas pensé trouver là les traces
du plus grand explorateur de fonds sous
marins du 20e siècle et pourtant
cousteau et bien d'ici
il est même question de créer une cuvée
calypso à l'origine de cette idée on y
vante un petit cousin de la famille
maternelle de cousteau aujourd'hui à la
tête de ses 17 hectares de vignes xavier
piton était adolescent qu'on cousteau
revenait dans cette belle demeure
familiale pour de joyeuses cousinade
dont il était le héros grave encore rien
c'est les cailloux les cailloux qui sont
là en pagaille et qui forme le sol le
sol de ce domaine et de ses photos
particulièrement
particulièrement intéressant pour la
vigne qui vaille exprimé avec beaucoup
de complexité l'ampleur et une aptitude
au vieillissement à ses incomparables
mais c'est du commandant cousteau vous
parlez là aussi ayant parlé comme ça
aussi voilà tout à fait tout à fait
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont parlé
d'ailleurs et quoi grand mère lui disait
il avait le même âge et il veut le coude
avec le même entrain
[Musique]
c'est une bouteille comme ça qu'il y
avait à bord à morgins calypso sûrement
il y en a eu sûrement oui il y en a eu
des plus récentes mais celle-là il en
abuse
c'était un homme de projets donc pour
lui de ne plus faire de projets ou ne
pas faire de projets c'était un non sens
de l'existence
son plus grand souci ça on en a parlé
plusieurs fois ensemble
c'est le problème de la démographie
mondiale et 10 comprend là on est temps
milliards et puis dans quelques années
on sera temps de plus est déjà là on
n'arrive pas à faire monter tout le
monde et donc on finira tous par crever
de faim au fil du voyage
j'apprends que l'homme au bonnet rouge
se livre un peu il ne détestait pas
brouiller les pistes mettre les vérité
intime comme les hommes en concurrence
peut-être pour ne retenir que les
meilleurs le pacha de la calypso aimait
par dessus tout la liberté
une patience séduisante et contagieuse
qu'il partagera avec le millier
d'équipier qui pendant plus de 40 ans se
relaieront sur ces bateaux des pionniers
de l'équipe cousteau
il ne reste aujourd'hui qu'une poignée
d'octogénaires tous en temps comme un
l'impossibilité de mettre le mot fin à
une histoire qu'ils savent unique et
inédite
[Musique]
l'un de ces aventuriers élevés au lait
cousteau est aujourd'hui l'un des
peintres sous marins les plus réputés au
monde le premier de l'histoire
oui
et
m
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour cheyrou est venu merci
c'est drôle hein de te retrouver
quelqu'un qui a un passé tant de temps
sur l'eau sous l'eau au coeur la série
est loin de la mer c'est ça ça a l'air
bien figurez-vous que on trouve des
fossiles non par ici donc ça prouve que
la mer et est ici bien avant que vous
arriviez et que j'arrive à là on est
dans votre atelier là c'est le festival
du bleu ah mais c'est la calypso là haut
c'est la calypso
c'est pas écrit dessus m'arrive de rêver
que je suis sur la calypso dans ces
circonstances et dans l'est des endroits
inconnus parfois il ya même pas la mer
mais souvent ça m'arrive jamais ailleurs
je n'aurais trouver ce que j'ai trouvé
sur la calypso et surtout au contact de
cet homme
alors à votre avis pourquoi avait-il à
ce moment-là besoin de quelqu'un avec
les compétences que vous aviez jamais
aucune compétence vous étiez ingénieur
chimiste malgré tes mais je sortais de
l'école je n'avais jamais travaillé dans
l'industrie
j'avais quelques connaissances
livresques mais mes jeux j'ai tout
appris sur la calypso de cousteau il
embaucher des gens il a recruté des
individus
divers horizons les qualifications
étaient pas importante du tout bien que
pour lui il sortait l'école navale mais
je me demande si il y avait un brevet de
plongée diplôme d'océanographie ou de
cinématographie je pense pas non
rendrait la banque a conçu et construit
lui-même cette caméra en matière
plastique les charges et le film exposé
au cours de la dernière plongée
dénicheur de talents cousteau a donc
senti que ce jeune bleu pouvait devenir
la tête pensante du bureau d'études de
l'office français de recherches
sous-marines qu'il venait de créer à
marseille avec les caméras étanches les
scooters des mers ces petites torpille
électrique fabriqué à partir des lices
récupérer à l'arsenal de toulon en sont
l'une des plus belles inventions héroïne
à part entière du monde du silence
inventer recyclé pour repousser les
frontières des profondeurs marines et
film est de plus en plus loin de plus en
plus longtemps
la soucoupe plongeante puis le
sous-marin monoplace mise au point par
andré lab en géo trouvetou en chef de la
calypso permettent à cousteau d'assouvir
ses fantasmes cinématographique
du silence repas eu lieu n'ont pas
existé sans gusto mais s'il a eu ce
succès si ça a été une réussite c'est
grâce à louis malle qui en était le
véritable metteur en scène et un immense
coup de chapeau à louis en 1965
andré la banc et cinq autres océanautes
sont les acteurs de l'un des rêves à la
jules verne du commandant permettra d
être humain de vivre durablement sous la
mer par 100 mètres de fond l'expérience
près continent trois entre dans
l'histoire mais cousteau cinéaste a déjà
immortalisé cette expérience de vie à
saturation dans le monde sans soleil
c'est une confortable habitations de
saint pierre en forme des toiles de mer
posée elle aussi à la profondeur de 11
mètres à proximité du hangar de la
soucoupe huit hommes 8 océanautes vont
ils vivre un mois plein ils sont soumis
sans la ressentir à une pression double
de la pression atmosphérique des hommes
bon vivre sous la mer comme le capitaine
nemo vingt mille lieues sous les mers
n'y pensais pas à cette époque là la
plonge et est connu mais est ce que et
bien on l'a vu cette chance parce que le
commandant et qui est un homme qui
prévoyait la hutte de demain saturées
tels hommes de demain le comment ce qui
était derrière cet effet c'était ont
magasiné si je peux dire achi mais ce
qu'on savait pas ce qu'ils savaient pas
chez effectuons vivre sous la mer avec
quelques rides de plus claude way sli
est toujours sur le pont il parcourt
l'europe pour transmettre aux enfants
la magie de l'odyssée cousteau pour moi
c'est l'homme qui m'a permis de réaliser
une grande partie de ma vie parce que
nous tous du seuil équipe si je peux
dire ainsi sans le commandant je pense
qu'on serait des inconnus parce qu'entre
defalco entre des vestri entre les
canaux et qui dit que cette vieille
équipe les dates chaud et compagnie
c'est toujours à travers le commandant
parce que sans le nom du commandant
cousteau je pense qu'on serait on serait
totalement oublié depuis fort longtemps
et peut-être même inconnu claude west
lil océanautes nous a confié regretter
ne pas être allé dans l'espace
les maisons sous la mère de cousteau
n'ont elles pas intéressé la nasa le
bonnet rouge symbole de liberté de
captain cousteau n'at-il pas été
embarqués dans une navette spatiale
après la fin de prêt continent 3 les
pétroliers par exemple qui avait été un
des sponsors de l'opération était prêt à
faire un pont d'or pour que nous nous
lancions les plongées profondes
industriel mais cousteau refuse et
probablement parce que il avait eu des
contacts avec les américains pour faire
une série de films pour la télévision et
que c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
l'intéressait beaucoup plus que le
travail et pour le pétrole mais s'est
jamais vendu le commandant nature était
un homme libre
donc quand on parle de vente marketing
comme on dit en anglais ça n'a jamais
été cela il était intéressé c'est vrai
dans le futur est médiatiquement parlant
alors on sait très bien tous ces films
qu'il a su tourner dans le monde entier
et que ces films étaient diffusées dans
le monde entier des cannes lions
française en priorité et ensuite aidé
les télés millions ça il a su le faire
sous l'eau l'oeil passe avant les
poumons disait coustous derrière son
masque de plongée
alors à quoi aurait servi cet oeil
averti sans la transmission des
connaissances
cette continuité cher à erik orsenna un
autre fou de mer qui en 99 a été
installé dans le fauteuil que l'immortel
au bonnet rouge avait laissé vacant j'ai
l'impression que jacques-yves cousteau
était d'une certaine manière un prof
c'est à dire il donnait des leçons de
mer il y aurait des leçons d'amazon des
leçons de deux fleuves des leçons
d'atlantique des leçons d'antarctique il
y donnait voilà il donnait à voir
il voulait qu'on comprenne qu on
s'émerveille et donc qu'on défende donc
quelqu'un qui est un prof passe le
relais mais dans l'idée que les autres
continuent et il était évident que
jacques perrin et le continuateur le
cousteau
ancien chef d'expédition sur la calypso
longtemps présenté comme le dauphin de
cousteau le plongeur au scénographe
françois sarano est aujourd'hui le
conseiller scientifique de jacques
perrin l'homme qui nagent avec le requin
blanc dans le film océans c'est lui on
voulait montrer qu'il y a une relation
possible entre un plongeur et plonge
librement un sans protection
particulière et le grand requin blanc et
le requin des dents de la mer
costaud c'est des films d' aventure
c'était des films d' équipe
il fit mais aussi bien les animaux que
ses équipiers que ces hommes qui avaient
la chance la chance extraordinaire que
d'aller que d'aller dans les sanctuaires
que d'aller à la rencontre ces animaux
c'était bien sûr qu'il avait une
connaissance scientifique mais c'était
pas avec cette approche c'était beaucoup
plus nous le nos carnets d' aventure et
ben voilà ce que l'on fait et on a une
chance inouïe
voilà on vous en rencontres tandis que
nous il n'y a pas de personnages on voit
pas d'homme on le voit un certain moment
mais c'est une symbolique mais il n'y a
pas de réalité d'un personnage qui
serait nommément précis non on reste nos
personnages principaux ce sont les
animaux mais ma crème malgré tout même
si on fait des choses différentes
même si on a une technique qui est
complètement révolutionnaire pour
accompagner ces animaux on va donc un
sillage dans le sillage de cousteau même
s'ils ont des différends un jour
un enfant qui découvrait la mère m'a
demandé je sais c'est quoi l'océan
[Musique]
il nous a montré comment évoluer sur le
fond c'est à dire de passer près du fond
évidemment sans jamais leur thé mais
suffisamment près pour que y'a pas un n
est ce pas trop importants dans l'image
et comment présenter les animaux ne pas
les prendre comme ça mais les présenter
la main dégager a failli avait
effectivement quelque chose qui se qui
se transmettaient cet intérêt s'assécher
coûts sont importants la transmission
quand je faisais très attention
je faisais très attention quand on
démarre et un plan je me disais déjà
tiens c'est là que je vais tourner parce
qu'ici il ya une sorte d'appui naturelle
du terrain et je vais pivoter autour
je sais qu'ici bas je vais je vais
expiré pour pouvoir baisser raser le
fond ans je vais m'élever tourner autour
de la gorgone pour venir mourir vers le
mérou qui voit là et tout ça ben on y
pensait on y pensait beaucoup à 80 ans
passés
bebert alias albert falco l'initiateur
de françois sarano sur la calypso
continue de filmer ses fonds sous marins
dans ces calanques natale qu'il voudrait
tant voir protéger
voilà peu près l'équipement qu'on avait
chez custo c'est-à-dire un mistral avec
les bulles qui se dégage un d'opa des
gilles est juste une légère ceinture
plombé qui permet de nager le plus
librement du monde oui l'esthétique
était important parce que c'est devrait
aussi le respect du spectateur
c'est le respect du spectateur sait
c'est lui dire voilà on se tient bien on
est propre on est élégant parce que la
nature que l'on découvre est belle
élégante et donc on voit là on n'y va
pas n'importe comment
on ne rentre pas n'importe comment
marre d'avoir connu ses coéquipiers de
cousteau voilà il emporte à la trace ils
emportent une empreinte quelque chose
qui est indélébile mais qui en même
temps je veux dire c'est pas parce
qu'ils ont fait partie de l'équipe de
cousteau que d'un seul coup ce sont des
personnages qui se vantent des
personnages qui savent plein de choses
non il ya beaucoup d'humilité je crois
que c'est la mère aussi apprend à être
humble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
si notre fonds de terre a parmi ses
titres de gloire celui d'avoir créé la
marine nationale
peu de marins ont eu l'honneur de siéger
à l'académie
encore fallait-il qu'il fuste homme de
lettres ou amiraux après les étoiles de
l'amiral la case ce seront mes modestes
galons qui représenteront la marine sur
la coupole la marine nationale a offert
à cousteau un tremplin large comme le
monde
en retour quel héritage lui at il laissé
l'histoire commence à la fin des années
trente du côté de toulon où il enseigne
de vaisseau de première classe jacques
yves cousteau est affecté son supérieur
le lieutenant de vaisseau philippe
taille elle va devenir son autre
lui-même
philippe taille elle lui présente l'un
de ses copains frédéric dumas le trio
des muscles mer et former l'archipel des
embiez devient le terrain de jeu et
d'expérimentation de ces fous de plongée
[Musique]
le cornac cousteau équipe taille azotés
leurs débuts imposé 6-4 en entonnant et
on a toujours un petit pincement aux
nouvelles savoir qu'ils ont
là c'est pas ça fait petit cowboy 3 mai
[Musique]
deux ans avant la mort de l'homme au
bonnet rouge tailler et cousteau les
deux frères de coeur se retrouve sur
cette plage mythique en offrant des
branchies à l'homme sous la mer le
scaphandre autonome révolutionne la
plongée sous-marine bandol ou vécu
cousteau et sanary village natal de
frédéric dumas conserve aujourd'hui la
mémoire des mosquées mer voici donc le
musée frédéric dumas amérique du nord
l'un des trois mousquetaires l'un des
trois mousquetaires et le plus d'actifs
de salariés de tous les muscles mais ok
alors je suis s'est passé avant
l'autonome chacun non c'est pas le
cerveau en scaphandre entendu que c'est
une réplique d'un costume du chevalier
de govan 10 715
c'est une première et c'est pour pouvoir
aller dans l'eau mais voyez que on a
déjà les prémisses eu tout ce qu'on va
rencontrer après c'est à dire qu'il faut
pouvoir aller dans l'eau il respirait
devoir se déplacer et donc c'est la 1er
le premier essai qu'on pourra aller dans
l'eau évidemment là le problème de tout
ça c'est vous être lié avec un tuyau
pour pouvoir avoir de l'ertt que vous
vous allez pouvoir respirer pour qu'au
dessus vous imaginez les gens qui
pompent vous avez vu le
le trésor de rackham le rouge avec les
deux dupont qui pompait ben là ils vont
y avait aussi des gens qui font très
serré le côté bon ce que les gens
paieraient c'est quand que vous êtes
dans l'eau vous avez une pression dont
claire a besoin d'être une certaine
pression plus vous descendez puis la
pression et vous pouvez pas avalé blair
qui était une pression supérieure à
l'air que vous respirez vous inspire
vous et moi quand on était l'atmosphère
donc il fallait d'étendre ses terres
donc on a commencé à faire des
détendeurs qui permettait étant dans le
fond de l'eau d'avoir quand même de
l'être à la pression qui allait bien
avec le détendeur bien entendu vedette
après qui était le cousteau gagnant 1 et
le fameux gagnant qui a été le cas et et
le détendeur gt on est passé à ce moment
là du du stade un peu de la plaisance et
du bricolage à un stade qui était plus
industrielle qui était plus scientifique
et au sortir de la guerre ce fameux
cousteau gagnant intéresse beaucoup les
autorités navales la rade de toulon est
bourré de mines et d'épaves le
scaphandre révolutionnaire qui permet à
l'homme de se transformer en poisson est
une aubaine cousteau surfé sur la vague
en créant le groupe de recherches
sous-marines une entité à part entière
de la royal
le cpie ce maire est aujourd'hui
l'héritier direct de l' aventure des
mousquetaires
[Musique]
donc la chronologie ce matin les
appareils sont prêts la check list a été
fait si c'est clair réparation de ton
genre
[Musique]
ces hommes sont des plongeurs d'armes
spécialisée dans le déminage
il teste aujourd'hui un nouvel
équipement de plongée nom de code le
crabe l'autorisation de faire descendre
pea dans la cuve
l'autorisation ferme en février
deux nouveaux opus
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que ce qui est en train de se passer là
dans le temps question qu'on a tout
simplement compris mais les plongeurs
dans une cuve d'eau pour reconfigurer
comme en milieu sous main comme en mer
l'appareil et les plonge concrètement on
est à une plongée de 32 m une
température de l'eau de 19 degrés donc
similaire à ce qu'on rencontre en
méditerranée habituellement
mais en réalité ils sont dans deux
mètres de profondeur liquide
pea vous m'entendez est-ce que c'est
conçu pour vous
il simule un pâle mal donc une
navigation
sous marine et de la surface on va gérer
tous les paramètres de la plongée et
notamment on va enregistrer tous les
paramètres des gaz qu'ils inspirent pour
pouvoir gérer ensuite leur profil de
désaturation des vestiges de l'histoire
le long des côtes de la manche au
conflit actuel
la guerre des mines nécessite un
matériel toujours plus performants
objectif permettre à ces plongeurs de
combat d'intervenir plus longuement
plus profondément et plus discrètement
c'était déjà l'objectif de cousteau le
but du jeu c'est pouvoir plonger le plus
longtemps possible et rester le moins
longtemps possible sous l'eau notamment
lorsqu'on travaille sur des mines
donc on leur fait pour respirer des
mélanges sûr que gêné pour puisse
plonger plus longtemps sans faire de
palier ou en faisant un minimum de
palier et ça c'est le vraiment le combat
que menait déjà pousse tous effet de
limiter le risque que les peaux qui
pourrait pas aussi bien équipés que nous
aidons qu'ils aient plus franc que le
rapidement surface
[Musique]
congés températures estivales ce que
vous m'avez entendu tout à l'heure
paraît très bien je n'ai que ça va très
bien mais je pense pas que ce soit
réciproque
bien après 1957 quand le capitaine de
corvette jacques yves cousteau la quitte
officiellement la royal continue de
fournir au pacha de la calypso des
marins expérimentés et respectueux et
des valeurs encore lent cousteau pris
par ses activités on aurait pu dire
qu'il s'était éloigné de la marine
mais on a retrouvé commandant cousteau
sur la fin de sa vie qui renouer et qui
a semble-t-il
rendu à la marine c'est un peu la marine
a attendu pendant quelques années
notamment avec le film qu'elle a fait en
mémoire d'un de ses anciens qui est le
commandant philippe taille et qui était
plongé dans la mémoire d'un mousquemers
et à l'occasion de ce film on a
effectivement pu découvrir un costaud
tout autre que on pouvait se l'imaginer
et qui était resté très attaché à son
pays et à la marine à sion parmi les
vies hors du commun que le héros de ce
film a contribué à forger celle du
docteur denis martin laval est sans
doute l'une des plus émouvantes
merci nous accueillir chez vous en prie
c'est donc là votre refuge
voilà ça c'était la maison principale
puis la calypso c'est votre résidence
secondaire
voilà c'est fait ce vétéran du monde du
silence vite à aubagne de 1954 à 1995
cet urologue de marseille pétri d
lecture de jules verne partage en tant
que médecin du bord une quinzaine
d'émissions de la calypso
ou à la visite et non académique et là à
cocher des commandes à madame mais le
souvenir le plus fort reste pour lui le
grand retour de cousteau en janvier 90
en antarctique c'est d'une beauté
je crois que c'est le plus beau voyage
que je fais et pourtant denis martin
laval avait été opéré trois semaines
avant son départ
par contre quand il me l'a proposé je
pensais que c'était en février
finalement c'était le 1er janvier je
suis parti
fou de joie avec un estomac au moins
presque avec les problèmes sérieux de
faire c'est pareil quand ans quand on
aime on compte 1 il faut chercher son
graal en soi
à ce moment là l'équipe cousteau à des
gens mémoire le souvenir des aventures
périlleuses la calypso coincé dans les
glaces du pôle sud dans les années 70
elle peut donc témoigner de la fragilité
du grand continent blanc avant les chefs
d'état cousteau et ses proches pressante
les dangers que représentent pour
l'ensemble de la planète l'exploitation
des ressources de l'antarctique à
commencer par le pétrole
en 81
cette 1987 cousteau dit dans le journal
dans les râles tribune qui a une
nouvelle convention qui vient d'être
adoptée pour exploiter les ressources
minérales de l'antarctique où ce taux a
pris un coup de sang et les miss et ils
sont fous on ne peut pas exploiter
le pétrole de l'antarctique même s'il en
a il faut garder comme une réserve il
faut le protéger il faut pas et si un
accident un bateau qui va la côte on
pourra jamais ray on pourra jamais
nettoyé et donc il a écrit un éditorial
et puis la fondation s'est demandé ce
qu'on pouvait faire et ont donc on a
lancé une pétition qui a été un cas
marché d'une façon incroyable on avait
soixante mille adhérents à l'époque un
journal tout des mois et on a mis une
pétition au milieu et on a reçu très
rapidement entre 20 et 30 mille
signatures par semaine on a déjà 190 g
nature et on en reçoit 12 à 13 milles
par jour 1c c'était y de fournir au
gouvernement français vous dites au
gouvernement français ne ratifiez pas
vous adresser au gouvernement et au
parlement des maladresses je ne suis pas
vraiment occupé du gouvernement quand on
met ça viendra mais demeure j'ai établi
une solide un solide appui populaire va
nous poserons la question michel rocard
jeudi dans questions à domicile ce qui
fera bon de la convention de washington
la france ne ratifiera pas le traité de
l'antarctique dans les conditions où il
est cousteau a raison de nous dire il
faut interdire purement et simplement
tout développement industriel et de
permettre que la recherche cousteau a
raison mais nous allons nous trouver
dans une situation diplomatique où je me
garderai bien de dire mieux vaut le
statu quo actuel n'importe qui pourrait
faire n'importe quoi et le commandant
cousteau le sait nous nous en avons
parlé tous les deux trois bons quarts
d'heure il le sait fort bien
il faut donc rouvrir la négociation
accueillir michel rocard est alerté par
un vieil ami le premier ministre
australien bob rock de la bombe
écologique et stratégique que serait
l'exploitation de l'antarctique
ensemble ils décident de monter au front
c'est l'effort ou ont commencé à
comprendre que le fait de brûler des
énergies fossiles produisait du gaz
carbonique donc du gaz à effet de serre
aggravé l'effet de serre et provoquer le
réchauffement climatique et les hommes
politiques sérieux et est obligé de
prendre ce doute en charge la décision
franco-australienne de non ratification
de la convention de washington a un
effet boule de neige en europe et en
urss
reste le plus difficile convaincre les
états unis de faire de l'antarctique un
sanctuaire
malheureusement dans toute cette affaire
on n'a pas des ddt
le seul français immensément populaire
aux états unis est populaire à cause
d'affaires d'écologie c'est costaud mais
il n'a jamais travaillé avec la
puissance publique on le connaît pas et
c'est alors je bondis là dessus je vais
fort je ne connaissais pas le commandant
cousteau et j'apprends que c'est un bon
bras jeu est fier avait très mauvais
caractère qu'il était difficile de
travailler avec lui et qu'en tout cas il
avait affiché depuis une vingtaine
d'années une méfiance absolue vis-à-vis
de l'état mettait un point d'honneur à
jamais recevoir des attaques d'argent
public et à préserver l'indépendance de
la fondation jacques yves cousteau
devant tout le monde et d'abord le vent
les politiques
je crois que c'est donc un dur à cuire
mais tous à l'aura internationale de
l'homme au bonnet rouge s'ajoutait la
force de frappe cinématographique avec
son film à lilliput en antarctique en
guise de sésame diplomatique
captain planet convainc un à un les
sénateurs américains de la nécessité de
ne pas aller chercher au pôle sud
les ressources pétrolières qu'il juge
indispensable le président bush en
personne écoute faith to fail
son plaidoyer pour l'antarctique
le français le plus célèbre aux états
unis décrochent l'un de ses meilleurs
titres de gloire et michel rocard
un de ses plus fameux coup politique et
c'est ainsi qu'a été adopté le troisième
le vrai troisième protocole au traité de
l'antarctique qui déclare l'antarctique
terre de sciences réserve naturelle
décide de la considérer comme un élément
du patrimoine de l'humanité et proclame
l'interdiction absolue sur tout le
territoire de l'antarctique de toute
activité humaine autre que touristique
ou de recherche donc pas d'activité
économique productrice de calories et
surtout de gasquet c'est une grande
victoire d'écologistes et aussi de ce
mariage
société civile est nu et hommes
politiques et aussi du rôle des médias
dire que je pense que sans cette
émission de 7 sur 7 s'arrête pas
basculer aussi vite ça reste vraiment
basculer parce que c'était dans le sens
de l'histoire mais cette ce moment il ya
des moments magiques comme ça qu'ils se
produisent et ça marche et je me
souviens de captain planet au sommet de
la terre à rio
invité par fidel castro à prendre place
sur la traditionnelle photo de famille
l'homme qui a résisté à l'invitation
pressante des écologistes français à se
lancer dans la course à la
présidentielle de 81 se voit élevé au
rang de chef d'état par les médias
bonjour
on ne naît pas écologiste on le devient
jacques yves cousteau n'a pas échappé à
la règle
paca les écrivains de bord et biographe
du commandant a été le témoin de cette
métamorphose
il a plusieurs fois embarqués sur la
calypso avec le plongeur denis ody aux
équipes cousteau de pas forcément
toujours protéger la faune non pour bien
du cinéma il ya pas mal de choses à dire
dans le monde du silence que sa grande
oeuvre qui l'a rendu célèbre dans le
monde entier
il ya des scènes à ces fameuses ou
frédéric dumas pêche à la dynamite pour
voir quelles sont les poissons du récif
et où les équipes et cousteau massacre
des requins parce que la calypso à tuer
afin blessé mortellement un petit
cachalots et requins arrive l'équipe i
plus haut tu les requins de cousteau là
dessus a été très ferme on avait
beaucoup de justesse de pons et on lui a
demandé 50 fois d'enlever ces scènes
dans le monde du silence et de remonter
de faire un film politiquement correct
et il a dit moi quand j'ai commencé le
piano graphie c'était le sien la graphie
du prince albert de monaco
c'est à dire que pour savoir ce que
mangeaient les dauphins ont harponner
les dauphins on ouvrait le montre regard
des skavens investement un des grands
apports de couteau a été de nous rendre
ami avec d'abord les baleines et
dauphins maintenant même les requins
tout le monde sait que les requins sont
en voie de disparition très menacé
la plus en plus de pulsions pour aller
protéger ses bêta ça s'est construit
historiquement on est passé d'un poste
aux montreurs de merveilles mon corps de
monde sous marin que personne ne
connaissait à un cousteau de plus en
plus écolo
équipier de cousteau début des années 90
denis ody milite aujourd'hui avec
acharnement pour la création au coeur
des canons de marseille d'un parc
national marin ça fait partie des
moments des très rares lieux qui sont
protégées autour de l'île de rügen
laisser encore un très petit goût du
projet de parc qui s'étendra donc un
parc national qui s'étendra
depuis cassis jusqu'à l'autre côté de la
baie en prenant une grande part de la
baie de marseille est pratiquement
jusqu'à deauville dollars
[Musique]
dans l'intérêt de ce parc national c'est
d'abord on a quand même une conjonction
d'un lieu magnifique que quand on arrive
en bateau ici c'est quand même un
endroit assez somptueux encore sauvage
toutes ces calanques sera assez sauvage
et en même temps à proximité immédiate
de deuxième ligne de france j'espère que
marseille aura l'intelligence de faire
un vrai pas avec une vraie ambition de
protection et on sait pour l'avoir
étudiée que quand on protège les
poissons dans une aire marine protégée
sur les zones alentours on en profite
les pêcheurs de ça et c'est pour ça
qu'ils défendent en soute selon temps
les pêcheurs ont été contre maintenant
ils commencent à changer un petit peu le
combat pour la sauvegarde de la
méditerranée la mer blessé aux yeux de
cousteau se poursuit une question
d'héritage
il m'a dit et vous savez j'ai vu des
spectacles du monde que personne ne
verra jamais plus des récifs de coraux
merveilleux des baisses plombiers des
forêts dans la mer des mangroves etc
il avait ajouté j'espère que quand vous
aurez mon âge vous n'aurez pas à dire la
même chose génération qui seront les
suivants et malheureusement évidemment
je dois dire que moi aussi j'ai vu des
spectacles du monde que personne ne
verra jamais plus que mes enfants vivent
pas que mes petits enfants ne verront
pas cousteau a quand même été un des
premiers à montrer que à la fois on
était tous dépendants de cette
biodiversité notamment de la mer et puis
que tout simplement pour le rêve des
enfants il fallait qu'on continue à
pouvoir bénéficier de cette
merveille de l'invention de la vie s'il
entre à l'académie c'est parce qu'il a
défendu la nature et dans ce que la
nature a deux à la fois de plus fort et
de plus fragiles peut-être c'est à dire
la mer mais il faut voir comment on
défend la nature et il suffit pas de
défendre la nature et de dire je défends
la nature de la nature encore faut-il le
faire avec talent avec un ton juste avec
des histoires avec des personnages avec
des mises en scène danse est un art de
défendre la nature c'est pas simplement
un voeu pieux et il a mis tout son
talent à cette défense
combien de dizaines voire de centaines
de millions de gens au mieux connue la
mer donc on mieux aimer la mer donc ont
mieux défendu la mer grâce à l'homme au
bonnet rouge
ah ben voilà albert 1er prince albert
1er qui est aux commandes là pas très
loin du musée mener à bien ce combat
pour la méditerranée le commandant
cousteau a pendant trente ans une sorte
de base arrière scientifique
le musée océanographique de monaco il
avait une vue magnifique sur le musée
d'ailleurs ce musée ironie du sort et
fondée en 1910 l'année de la naissance
de l'homme au bonnet rouge
ce temple de l'océanographie lui était
pour ainsi dire prédestiné le prince
albert 1er et et on va dire un
explorateur fait partie la société de
géographie des explorateurs donc on peut
dire que prince albert non seulement été
un des pères de l'océanographie pas que
c'est grâce à lui que le salon graphie a
fait de grands progrès c'était une
séance toute nouvelle et on a encore
beaucoup de choses à apprendre
donc il a laissé ce magnifique écrin
qu'est le musée océanographique en
voulant construire ce bâtiment pour
abriter ses collections et en 57 le
commandant est arrivé alors le
commandant bien évidemment c'est le
commandant qui a fait connaître et ce
musée océanographique parce que chaque
fois qu'une mission de la calypso par tl
parti de monaco avec la contribution du
et l'aide du musée océanographique et
c'est comme ça
souvent que l'on entendait dire le musée
costaud donc voila vous rendre sur les
traces du commandant cousteau bien vous
avez ici donc un témoignage donc c'était
le 14 avril 62 le prince rainier la
princesse grace qui viennent au musée et
que acquis le commandement présente
cette nouvelle exposition qui s'appelait
l'homme sous la mer il y avait une
grande proximité entre le couple renier
et jacques yves cousteau oui oui je le
prince souverain a toujours été très
comment dire soucieux de ce qui se
passait au musée et donc de ce fait donc
été en relation donc fréquentes avec le
commandant cousteau forcément le héros
du monde du silence a légué au musée un
aquarium deux fois plus vaste qu à son
arrivée développer les laboratoires un
dépoussiérage en règle pour transformer
ce palais de la mer en une vitrine
engagé dans la protection de
l'environnement une tribune
internationale de l'écologie je crois
qu'il a compris que le musée serait pour
lui un endroit extraordinaire pour
l'aider dans tout ce qu'il faisait mais
je crois aussi que ceux qui lassés a
rayonné sur le musée inversement et tout
le monde peut-être a été gagnant dans la
ferme en fête le centenaire quand on
peut mais on le fait
côté déjà de pouvoir le fêter il s'était
échappé
[Musique]
tél
et voilà
je vous
réunir dans un même éclat l'art et la
science
pour son centenaire le musée
océanographique fait appel à l'artiste
en vogue damiano oft pour donner une
nouvelle jeunesse à cette alchimie cher
au prince navigateur son fondateur et à
son arrière arrière petit fils le prince
albert ii c'est vraiment le concours ce
taux qui a fait qu'il fait vivre ce
cette institution pendant comme en tout
30 ans qui l'a amené dans une modernité
dans une prise de conscience du public
en général sur les problèmes liés aux
maires et aux océans et qui a fait
vraiment qui a fait aimer et qui a
suscité des vocations je rencontre tout
le temps des scientifiques qui qui me
disent ah mais on fait ce que l'on fait
parce qu'on a été touché par ce que nous
avons montré le congo au sto lorsqu'on
était jeune j'ai toujours regretté
d'ailleurs de ne pas être parti demain
pu rejoindre la calypso à certaines de
ces de ses escales lors de lors de cette
exposition
il a été vraiment formidable pédagogue
et quelqu'un qui savait faire aimer la
mer et savait faire partager tous les
mystères et tous les trésors qu'elle
qu'elle recèle
[Musique]
où
vous
l'alcyone la fille du vent le navire
amiral de la nouvelle équipe cousteau
continue de sillonner les mers
dès le début des années 80 cousteau le
visionnaire veut démontrer aux
écolo-sceptiques que l'énergie éolienne
gratuite propre et inépuisable à un
avenir à condition d'être domestiquer
cette domestication à un nom sur hbo
voile alors même si je comprends bien on
fait un bateau à voile et à moteur c'est
ça bateaux à voile et à moteur
exactement on a deux moteurs de 200
chevaux qui nous font avancer à une
vitesse d'environ 10 me de ça c'est le
premier principe du bateau et le second
c'est quand on se déplace d'un point à
un autre
on va donc conserver cette vitesse et
puis on va utiliser quand les vents sont
favorables on va utiliser les turbos
voile non pas pour augmenter la vitesse
du navire mais va nous paraître d'avoir
utilisé mois la puissance d'un moteur et
qui dit bien sûr réduction de puissance
moteur dit forcément économies d'énergie
pour relever son pari cousteau fait
appel à un membre de l'académie des
sciences est un architecte naval réputé
lucien malavard et andré maury vous avez
aussi une perspective en charles now et
bertrand charrier sont à l'époque les
deux élèves de ses éminents spécialistes
ensemble ils mettent au point les
premiers navires hybrides de l'histoire
à d'abord il faut savoir comment marche
un bateau à voile
car le vent passe au poteau de la voile
est dévié par la voix et on a une force
qui tire le bateau vers l'avant dans
cette force et fonction évidemment la
vitesse du vent et la surface de la
voile ratures vos voix vous avez vu
c'est un profil très épais avec des
trous sur l'arrière quand le vent arrive
ici le vent passe autour de la voile
mais la turbo vaines et s'il n'y avait
pas ces petits trous le vent irait tout
droit mais grâce à ces petits trous le
vent fait ça il est dévié très fortement
parce que on a un ventilateur qui étend
au delà thurgovien qui aspire l'air et
qui rentrent les risques et qui pour
cette délégation est alors à ses
déviations fait que la force qui créent
et cinq fois supérieur en moyenne a
cette force-là donc
pour une même surface où une même corde
de voile une même surface
on a une force qui est cinq fois
supérieur sur n'actionne de les calculs
qu'on a fait était à peu près entre 25
et 30 % d'économie de carburant ce qui
est assez 13 qui est très importante
une invention que l'homme d'affaires
courteau sourd à vendre à la société
pechiney ancien patron des ateliers
chantiers navals du oeuvre gilbert
fournier n'a rien oublié de ce défi
écologique et industriels en avance sur
son temps la société pechiney avait
obtenu un accord de la cgem pour faire
un essai et d'économie d'énergie sur un
pétrolier au transport de marchandises
diverses de la commande générale
maritime et les pétrole le pétrole est
redescendu les trajets se sont
raccourcis parce qu'on aurait ouvert
suel c'était l'époque où on avait fermé
suel et du coup c'était plus
économiquement valable mais aujourd'hui
ça peut le redevenir
évidemment qu'il faut choisir des types
de bateaux pour lequel une turbo voile
sur le pont n'est pas un handicap de
l'exploitation vais y en a plusieurs et
beaucoup de types de bateaux qui
répondent à ce critère qu'en fait on
imagine x sont des plus grands bateaux
il puisse y avoir 3 ou 4 turbo voile et
on sait qu'il ya un certain nombre de
projets comme ça qui est qu'ils sont
dans la nature qui se feront peut-être
un jour quand voilà on espère on pense
aujourd'hui quand même que la turbo vol
n'a pas dit son dernier mot aujourd'hui
on est sur une
le prix de l'énergie évidemment mais
aussi la destruction de l'environnement
les émissions de co2 ces changements
climatiques et ça c'est aussi une vraie
menace dans la perspective de
développement durable
aujourd'hui donc y est un peu différente
l'alcyone petite soeur de la calypso le
navire mythique de l'épopée cousteau lui
attend de reprendre la mer depuis ce
jour où une barge pétrolière la
précipiter au fond du port de singapour
c'est la mona lisa des océans ma volonté
de continuer est absolument intacts j'ai
pas acheté les moteurs pour mettre la
galette un musée je dis simplement que
c'est une entreprise difficile que il
est probable que en france on n'a pas
encore trouvé une motivation positive
pour m'aider ça c'est vrai mais j'en ai
trouvé ailleurs pour le moment
j'aurais préféré quand même que mon pays
reconnaissent qu'il détient non
seulement un des hommes qui a le plus la
mémoire d'un homme qui a le plus
participé au rayonnement de la france
dans le monde à bord de ce bateau
petit point sur le mexique parce que
vous allez y revenir bientôt
noémie aujourd'hui l'équipe cousteau
mise sur les générations futures cher à
son père fondateur pour protéger leur
patrimoine
elle met en place des observatoires des
mères avec en guise de philosophie
politique et scientifique les côtés cnis
ce concept inventé par captain planet il
ya plus de vingt ans vise à faire de
l'écologie de l'économie de la technique
et des sciences humaines le socle
universitaire d'un développement durable
un réseau de 15 cher d'ecotecnic
ordonnée par l'unesco sous la
responsabilité du suédois peter dauxais
existe déjà dans le monde sans laisser
une trace
mes chers d'ecotecnic c'est des
institutions très efficace travers la
proche des coûts techniques où ce taux a
aussi aidé l'unesco a travaillé
aujourd'hui van éducation vers le
développement durable éducation pour le
développement
donc c'est cher d'ecotecnic cette
association avec l'unesco
cette volonté de former les gens de
façon multidisciplinaire de façon à ce
qu'ils prennent des décisions plus
avisées
c'est lié aux droits des générations
futures le commandant comme vous le
savez s'était battu pour une charte des
droits des générations futures qui je
dirais qu'il ya ce qui est en route
parce que ça prend beaucoup de temps
mais quelques mois après sa mort elle a
été adoptée au niveau de l'assemblée
générale dé l'unesco
il faut certes qu'elle monte encore au
niveau de des nations unies
[Musique]
pierre-yves le plus jeune des fils du
commandant cousteau travail à fédérer
les plongeurs du monde entier pour en
faire des sentinelles de la nature je
pense que nous sommes tous les héritiers
du commandant cousteau
parce qu'il nous a laissée à tous une
conscience de la planète une conscience
un amour de la mer un amour de la nature
et ça il l'a il a donné à tout le monde
donc on se sent cela je me sens pas plus
son héritier qu'un autre mais j'ai la
chance de pouvoir essayer de continuer
son oeuvre est de porter son oeuvre
dans l'avenir et j'espère
possible
diplômé en sciences spatiales
pierre-yves rêve du jour où l'on pourra
établir une communication en direct
entre un plongeur et un cosmonaute
l'océan le cosmos vision intérieure
extérieure d'une planète que l'immortel
au bonnet rouge attend défendu avec la
pesanteur en héritage
[Musique]
le
et
[Musique]
bienvenue à vous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle émission spéciale d'ushuaïa tv
le 25 juin 1997 alors que s'achever à
new york le sommet de la terre c'est
aigner à paris celui qui restera sans
doute comme l'un des grands précurseurs
de l'écologie le commandant jacques yves
cousteau le pacha de la calypso et enée
87 ans plus tôt en juin 1910 à se tendre
et de cubzac en gironde au coeur du
vignoble bordelais 1910-2010 toute
l'année ushuaïa tv est partenaire des
célébrations du centenaire de la
naissance de ce grand cinéaste et
explorateur des fonds sous-marins que
fut le commandant cousteau
vous pourrez revoir en version
remastérisée le monde du silence bien
sûr palme d'or au festival de cannes
1956 à film réalisé avec la complicité
de louis malle le monde son soleil qui
retrace l'un des épisodes des maisons
sous la mer et bien sûr voyage au bout
du monde
récit de ces quatre mois d'aventuré
périlleuse en antarctique un film
réalisé en 1975
mais la méditerranée fut sans doute la
première muse la mer des vocations
multiples de jacques yves cousteau de
toulon à monaco en passant par marseille
sanary nous avons suivi les traces du
commandant cousteau les mortels au
bonnet rouge
cousteau l'immortel away des rouges
merci à vous d'avoir partagé ce voyage
et pour clore cette émission spéciale je
vous propose de découvrir ce film laissé
en héritage deux ans avant sa
disparition par le commandant cousteau
un film réalisé avec la complicité de
francine cousteau profond loin longtemps
à très vite sur ushuaïa tv